eventually I decided that I wanted to go
home and Andrew walked me out got up
like a gentleman pulled me to the front
of the building and he ordered me an
Uber home and he ordered me an XXL
executive the most over-the-top
extravagant Uber there is he paid for it
and he said to the Uber driver this is
my wife please make sure you look after
her make sure she gets home safely
otherwise he'd have him to deal with I
thought that was very very nice um he
was being very gentlemanly making sure
that I got home safely which is totally
different and in contrast to what social
media is saying about him and saying
that he hates women women I mean clearly
none of that is true in my personal
experience so far I've been with him
alone with his brothers
um and nothing negative has happened
I've always felt very protected and very
comfortable and he texted me to make
sure that I got home okay Andrew says
that women are the most precious things
on the planet and they need to be
protected and that certainly felt true
it felt like he really meant what he
said